mr schumer
mr scott of florida
mr scott of south carolina
mrs shaheen
mr shelby
with cinema
it's not
miss davenau
mr sullivan
mr tester
mr thin
mr tillis
mr timmy
mr tuberville
mr van hollen
mr warner
mr warnock
[Music]
miss warren
mr white house
mr waker
mr wyden
mr young
senators voting in the affirmative
burr cantwell collins
coons duckworth durbin
heinrich kelly lujan
mansion murphy murray
peters reed shots shaheen
smith warner whitehouse
senators voting in the negative cotton
cramer crapo graham
sas scott of south carolina
young
mr chester mr chester aye
mr king mr king i
[Music]
no
[Music]
the cinema cinema
mr brown mr brown aye
mr padilla mr padilla
aye mr kennedy mr kennedy
no
mr inhofe mr inhofe
no
mr schumer mr schumer aye mr leahy mr
leahy
aye
mr blumenthal mr blumenthal
aye
[Music]
[Music]
islamist islamists know
this baldwin miss baldwin aye
[Music]
mr booker mr booker uh
this game mr kane aye
mr van hollen mr van hollen aye mr
bozeman
mr boseman no mr carper mr carper
mr paul mr paul no
[Music]
mr merkley mr markley i
mr cassidy mr cassidy aye
mr lankford mr lankford
[Music]
no
[Music]
so
mr casey mr casey i
miss hassan it's hassan
i
[Music]
[Music]
mr tillis mr tillis aye mrs feinstein
mrs feinstein i
mr shelby mr shelby no
miss warren miss warren aye
mr markey mr markey aye
mr hawley mr hawley no
[Music]
you're taking over mr hickenlooper aye
[Music]
mr menendez mr menendez aye mr lee mr
lee
no
mr warnock mr warnock
aye mr widen mr widen
aye mr ossoff mr ossoff
i
rubio mr rubio
[Music]
garden mr cardin ah mr rounds mr rounds
no
mr sanders mr sanders i
i
so
[Music]
mr cornyn
mr cornyn
mr sullivan mr sullivan
no mr grassley mr grassley aye
mrs cappatoe mrs capital i
miss ernst mr ernst no
mr toomey mr toomey now
this is fisher mrs fisher i
mr barrasso mr barrasso
no
mr tune mr thune no
mr bennett mr bennett aye
[Music]
mr wicker mr wicker no mr scott mr scott
florida
no miss murkowski miss murkowski
aye
this is jill around this is jill around
[Music]
aye
mrs hyde smith mrs hyde smith
no mr johnson mr johnson aye
miss davenau miss davenau i
[Music]
mr portman mr portman hi
[Music]
that's clever charm it's clever char
i
[Music]
i
hagerty mr hagerty now
[Music]
me
mr rash mr rash
[Music]
no
mr mcconnell mr mcconnell
[Music]
if
oh
mr cruz mr cruz no
[Music]
mr brawn mr braun no
mr romney mr romney
i
[Music]
mr hoeven mr hovind
no
so
let's vote the yeast of 64 the nasir 33
the nomination is confirmed
under the previous order the motion to
reconsider is considered made and laid
upon the table
and the president will be immediately
notified of the senate's actions
the clerk will report the motion to
invoke cloture
your motion we the undersigned senators
in accordance with the provisions of
rule 22 of the standing rules of the
senate
to hereby move to bring to a close
debate on executive counter number eight
gina marie raimondo of rhode island to
be secretary of commerce signed by 17
senators
by unanimous consent the mandatory
quorum call has been waived the question
is is it the sense of the senate the
debate on the nomination
of gina marie raimondo of rhode island
to be secretary of commerce shall be
brought to a close
the yeas and nays are mandatory under
rule under the rule the clerk will call
the role
ms baldwin mr barrasso
mr bennett mrs blackburn mr blumenthal
mr blunt mr booker mr bozeman
mr braun mr brown
[Music]
oh
wow
[Music]
mr brown mr burr miss cantwell
mrs capito mr cardin
mr carper mr casey mr cassidy
ms collins mr coons
mr cornyn ms cortes masto mr cotton
mr kramer
mr crapo mr cruz
mr james ms duckworth mr durbin
ms ernst mrs feinstein mrs fisher mrs
gillibrand
mr graham mr grassley
mr hagerty miss hassan
mr hawley mr heinrich
mr hickenlooper
[Music]
miss hirono mr hoeven mrs hyde smith
mr inhofe mr
johnson mr kane mr kelly
mr kennedy mr king
ms klobuchar mr langford
mr leahy mr lee mr lujan
ms lummus
mr mansion mr markey mr marshall
mr mcconnell mr menendez mr merkley
mr moran ms murkowski
mr murphy
mrs murray mr ossoff
mr padilla mr paul mr peters
mr portman mr reed
mr risch mr romney ms rosen mr rounds mr
rubio
mr sanders mr sass mr schatz
mr schumer
mr scott of florida mr scott of south
carolina
mrs shaheen mr shelby
miss cinema miss smith miss stavenow mr
[Music]
sullivan
mr tester mr thune mr tillis
mr toomey mr tuberville mr van hollen
mr warner mr warnock ms warren
mr whitehouse mr wicker
mr wyden
mr young
this
[Music]
okay
[Music]
senators voting in the affirmative
bennett
booker bozeman braun
brown burr capitao
cardin harper casey cassidy
collins cornyn cortez masto
crapo duckworth durbin
ernst feinstein fisher
gillibrand grassley hassan
hirono hyde smith johnson
kane kelly leahy
lee lujan mansion
marky marshall mcconnell
menendez merkley murkowski
murphy murray ossoff padilla
paul peters portman
reed rish romney
rosen rounds schatz shaheen
cinema smith stavenow
tester tillis toomey van hollen
warnock warren whitehouse wyden
and young mr sanders mr sanders
i
senators voting in the negative barrasso
cotton cruz hagerty
holly kennedy lummus
rubio scott of florida shelby
and tuberville
mr heinrich mr heinrich ah
mr hoeven mr hoeven no
mr inhofe mr inhofe i
[Music]
few
mr coons mr coons ah
mr langford mr langford ah
[Music]
[Music]
mr moran mr moran ah
mr kramer mr kramer no
mr hickenlooper mr hickenlooper ah
mr graham mr graham i
mr king mr king ah
foreign
foreign
mr warner mr warner i
miss cantwell miss cantwell ah
[Music]
uh
now
just
mr blumenthal mr blumenthal ah
[Music]
mr schumer mr schumer ah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
easy
mr thune mr thune ah
mr wicker mr wicker aye mr sasse mr
sasse
[Music]
foreign
okay
so mr danes mr danes
[Music]
ah
chance
ms baldwin miss baldwin
[Music]
mr blunt mr blunt aye ms klobuchar miss
klobuchar
mr sullivan mr sullivan
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
more
this
go
mr scott mr scott of south carolina no
[Music]
[Music]
hey
mr sass mr sass
no
are there any senators in the chamber
wishing to vote or to change
his or her vote if not the a's are 84
the nays are 15 and the motion is agreed
to
clerk will report the nomination
nomination
department of commerce gina marie
raimondo of
rhode island to be secretary
mr president senator from georgia
mr president as if in legislative
session i ask unanimous consent the
senate proceed to the consideration of
senate resolution 82
submitted earlier today
senate will be in order please
clerical report senate resolution 82
honoring the life and legacy of john
robert lewis and commending
john robert lewis for his towering
achievements in the non-violent struggle
for civil rights
is there objection to proceeding to the
measure
without objection the senate will
proceed
mr president i ask unanimous consent the
resolution be agreed to
the preamble be agreed to and that the
motions to reconsider be considered
made and laid upon the table with no
intervening action or debate
is there objection without objection
i yield
mr president
from iowa mr president from the streets
of portland
and seattle to right here in our
nation's capital
lawlessness has ensued all too often
across our nation over the past year
i have consistently called it
what it is anarchy and folks we need to
be
absolutely clear on this anarchy
cannot be tolerated in our nation
the mayhem that we have seen over the
last year has put our
families our communities
and our law enforcement
in danger and tragically
it has led to death and destruction
in what will probably come as no shock
to the american people
a nonpartisan watchdog organization
found
that the federal government has spent
more than 14
billion dollars of our taxpayer money
our hard-earned dollars on federal
contracts and grants
in five major cities where civil
unrest also known as anarchy
goes unchecked and police
are unable to do their job
14 billion with a b
dollars paid to local leaders
and city officials who are failing
to do their jobs and let's keep talking
about these dollar figures folks
according to recent reports by local
media
in oregon left-wing protests in portland
have caused roughly 2.3
million dollars in damage
to federal buildings since they broke
out last
summer the near nightly standoffs with
police
involved graffiti broken windows
firecrackers as well as well as molotov
cocktails
according to one u.s attorney in oregon
cleanup at the courthouse and four other
government buildings has cost more than
two million dollars and that number
could
keep going up because the repairs are
ongoing
last year i pushed for a review of any
federal funding that was going to the
cities and states
that were allowing anarchy
to run rampant it was a simple
ask scrutinize any future federal
funding
that might flow into these lawless
jurisdictions
specifically i asked the office of
management and budget
to look into and report to the american
people
the amount of taxpayer dollars local
officials used to either sustain
these autonomous zones or the amount
needed to
repair the damage done during the chaos
and thankfully last year the federal
government began to
do just that but folks just last week
president biden reversed this effort
and i'd like to know why now i agree
with our new president that
peaceful protests are a cornerstone
of our democracy but smashing
windows is not protesting
and neither is looting burning small
businesses that are the modest nest eggs
of hard-working americans and actions
like these are
totally unacceptable
don't think there's anyone in the senate
that would disagree
so why then is president biden
reversing course and preventing
this review from going forward to simply
examine the funds that are going to the
very
places where lawlessness continues
to be unanswered too often over the last
year
local leaders have prevented
law enforcement and emergency responders
from being allowed to carry out their
jobs and protect the public
yet millions of our taxpayer dollars
have still been doled out to these
cities
i will continue to stand strong and be a
voice
for the hard-working taxpayers of this
country
if city and state leaders abdicate
their job to protect citizens and allow
anarchist jurisdictions to prevail
the federal government iowa taxpayers
should absolutely not foot
the bill anarchy is never
okay never okay
and taxpayers should never subsidize it
thank you mr president i yield the floor
[Music]
uh
yes
this
yes
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
uh
as if in legislative session i ask
unanimous consent to the senate proceed
to the consideration of senate res 83
submitted earlier today clerical report
senate resolution 83 expressing support
for the designation of february 20
through february 27
2021 as national ffa
week and so forth
is there objection to proceeding to the
measure
without objection the senate will
proceed
mr president i ask unanimous consent the
resolution be agreed to
the preamble be agreed to and that the
motion to reconsider
be considered made and laid upon the
table with no intervening action
or debate is your objection
without objection mr president i
ask unanimous consent that when the
senate completes its business today
it recesses until 10 30 a.m on tuesday
march 2nd
that following the prayer and pledge the
journal of proceedings be approved to
date
the time for the two leaders be reserved
for their use later in the day
morning business be closed and the
senate proceed to executive session
to resume consideration of the raimondo
nomination
that at 2 15 pm the cloture time be
considered expired
and the senate vote on confirmation of
the nomination
that if confirmed the motion to be
considered be considered made and laid
upon the table
and the president be immediately
notified of the senate's action
and finally that senator cruz be
recognized at 12
15 pm for up to 30 minutes and following
his remarks
the senate recesses until 2 15 p.m
for the weekly conference meetings it's
your objection
without objection for the information of
senators there will be two roll call
votes at 2 15 pm
the first vote will be on confirmation
of the raimondo nomination to be
secretary of commerce
followed by a cloture vote on the rouse
nomination to be chair
of the council of economic advisers if
there is no further business to come
before the senate i ask that it recess
under the previous order
senate stands in recess until 10 30 a.m
tomorrow
you